bueno primero una cuestión inmunitaria
es decir las diferentes plataformas ya
han demora están demostrando que tienen
inclusive mejor inmunidad que las
vacunas que son de una misma plataforma
esto es esto es algo reciente el segundo
punto es que si yo puedo combinar
vacunas los gobiernos pueden comprar
diferentes vacunas y pueden implementar
más fácil los programas de vacunación
entonces esto es esto da equidad al
mundo al acceso a imagínense que la
mitad del hemisferio norte tiene
producto bruto interno los mayores y
acceden a muchas vacunas con la
reticencia que tienen por ejemplo eeuu
30 por ciento pero los países del
hemisferio sur es decir en latinoamérica
y el caribe asia y áfrica no puede estar
solamente enfocados en una vacuna que
pueden comprar sino que van a tener que
depender también de entes
internacionales de ayuda en algunos de
los casos y entonces la mezcla de
vacunas la vacunación es hetero lo van a
permitir un mayor acceso también desde
el punto de vista sanitario